we are delighted to bringing the seminar
presented by lab roots and in
collaboration with the National
Institute of Health welcome to our track
on the NIH brain initiative a
multidisciplinary approach to
neuroscience we're glad you could join
us for this panel presentation titled
the neural control of locomotion an
integrative approach it's my pleasure to
introduce a panel of experts who will be
speaking on the topic of advancing human
neuroscience for a full listing please
click on the tab at the top of your
screen if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the Q&A box our speakers respond
back to you via email as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits tab
located in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
please join me in welcoming our panel of
experts hi my name is Michael Dickinson
and I'm a professor of biology and
bioengineering at the California
Institute of Technology I'd like to
welcome you to this panel presentation
entitled the neural control of
locomotion an integrative approach the
locomotion of humans and other animals
requires a seamless flow of information
from sensory modalities all the way to
the motor periphery as such locomotion
is an excellent system for understanding
how the brain modifies neural signals
from one processing stage to the next
ultimately transforming sensory signals
into a code that controls motor output
and behavior locomotion is also the
means by which animals execute many
essential behaviors such as dispersal
foraging courtship and escape the
presentations in this panel represent a
sample of the work being conducted by a
consortium of seven laboratories
supported by a u19 grant through the
brain initiative at NIH our research
exploits a single experimentally
tractable model organism the fruit fly
Drosophila melanogaster in which we can
easily study the function of genetically
identified cell classes and ecologically
relevant behaviors the talks in this
panel all delivered by graduate students
and postdocs the people who actually do
the work will highlight a range of
experimental approaches that
collectively constitutes a systematic
attack on the neural basis of behavior
that integrates vertel vertically across
phenomenological tiers the transect runs
roughly from the local motor circuits
that control the action of individual
limb muscles through central circuits
that regulate patterns of locomotion to
the behavioral strategies that animals
employ when they use their local motor
capabilities to search for food the
first talk will be presented by dr. Tony
Acevedo a postdoctoral researcher in the
lab with John Tuthill at the University
of Washington Tony will describe how the
genetic tools available in Drosophila
make it possible to study the local
sensory motor circuits in the ventral
nerve cord a structure that's roughly
analogous to the spinal cord in
vertebrates these important of these
important local circuits regulate forces
generated by individual limb muscles and
form the foundation of all behaviors
executed by a limb motion the second
talk will be presented by Clare Howard
who is an MD PhD student in the lab of
Richard Mann at Columbia Clare will
discuss how the neuromodulators
serotonin regulates local motor pattern
through its coordinated action on local
sensory motor circuits of the ventral
nerve cord this work is an excellent
example of how nervous systems news
neuromodulation to increase the
functionality of locomotor networks the
third talk will be presented by luke
reza beck a graduate student and Tom
Clinton's lab at Stanford Luke will
describe new techniques for conducting
whole brain imaging and in fact behaving
flies these techniques to which
Drosophila is particularly well suited
make it possible to quickly map the
function of different brain regions as
animals execute specific behaviors Luke
is using this approach to identify
regions of the brain that are in
in the visual control of steering the
theme of steering will be continued in
the fourth talk which will be presented
by dr. sasha rice ships he who recently
completed his PhD in Rachel Wilson's lab
at Harvard Medical School sasha has
identified in a treatment pair of
descending neurons with inputs in the
brain and outputs in the ventral nerve
cord descending neurons are a critical
class themselves because they said
exactly midway in the process of sensory
motor transformation the selva sasha has
discovered appears to function as a
command neuron for steering the fifth
and final talk will be presented by
Emily Palmer who is a second-year
graduate student in my lab at Caltech
Emily will describe new behavioral
experiments aimed at understanding how
animals keep track of their position in
space as they walk by measuring
distances travel in each direction
animals can potentially plot a course
back to any salient location in their
environment
a form of spatial memory called path
integration emily will also show how we
make use of mathematical models to test
predictions of the hypotheses that
emerge from our experimental results so
collectively this series of thoughts
illustrates our team's goal to develop a
comprehensive theory of animal behavior
they explicitly incorporates neural
processes operating across hierarchical
levels from circuits that regulate the
action have been individual muscles to
those that regulate behavioral sequences
and decisions so thanks for logging in
to watch I hope you enjoy the
presentations and the next talk is from
Tony as the Vado all right thank you
Michael all right so my name is Tony
Acevedo and I work in John tuthill's
laboratory at the University of
Washington and I'm going to tell you
today about the neural control of leg
movements and flies and I just like to
point out the beginning of the talk that
we had help from people in the title lab
including Evan Dickinson and relax sugar
ohm and then we also got started with
help from Richard man who's a member of
this group specifically we'll want even
cought who helped us
find tools and reagents to really get
started okay so the title lab works on
how the nervous system controls walking
flies and flies are great walkers they
spend a lot of time walking around
finding food and mates and places to
play to lay eggs and they step about ten
times per second so that's quite fast
and requires a lot of coordination of
the limbs and we won't understand how
the nervous system controls that pattern
of muscle contractions and as a result
been used applies as a model for
locomotion across animal species so but
when we got started we really had no
good measurements of basic parameters of
leg movements and particularly how much
force is produced by a muscle
contractions and which motor neurons are
controlling them so that's what we set
out to do initially so just as
background here's an image of a fly leg
each leg six legs and all each leg has
five segments and 14 muscles controlling
positions of their segments so those
seconds includes a coxa the trochanter
the femur and the tibia and the Tarsus
which is not shown here and then 14
muscles and each muscle is then composed
of several muscle fibers and each muscle
fiber is innervated by motor neuron and
a motor neuron innervates a group of
muscle fibers so here in red I'm showing
you a stain of the muscle fibers and you
can see several grouped into muscles in
the femur here I'm going to point out
the femur in particular and then here's
a in green there's a motor neuron axon
that's leaving the nervous system and
projecting into the leg and you can see
that this one innervates has a large
axon terminal that integrates several
muscle fibers within this muscle in the
femur so this neuron
controls contraction in a muscle that
results in tibia flexion so it closes
the angle between femur and tibia and
it's one of several that control tibia
flexion so we want to understand a very
basic thing how are the neurons that
control one direction of movement in
this case tibia flexion organized to
produce different amounts of force and
together cause contraction of the tibia
so to do this we set out to find genetic
reagents that label individual motor
neurons in the central nervous system
that project to the femur so here I'm
showing you what we've what we're
calling the fast the intermediate and
the slow motor neurons they controlled
tibia flexion so starting on the left
appear the fast motor neuron has a very
large axon terminal that grabs on to a
lot of muscle fibers they're all in the
tibia flexor muscle the intermediate
neuron projects this is what I showed
you in the last slide this projects to
the more proximal fibers within that
same muscle and then finally the slow
motor neuron if you're looking just at
the leg projects all the way out to the
distal tip of these of the femur and
innervates only one or two muscle fibers
in that region and then below I'm
showing you what the dendrites in the
ventral nerve system look like for the
fast the intermediate and the slow tibia
flexor motor neurons and you can see
that the extent of the dendrites in the
ventral nervous system near some extent
the the patterns of axons the size of
the axon terminals out in the leg okay
so we found these tools that label these
individual neurons and then we wanted to
understand how they function
individually and how they work together
to control to the inflection
so we developed a preparation where we
could do electrical recordings from
these motor neurons we targeted
we targeted our electrophysiological
pipettes to the cell bodies of these
neurons and at the same time we then
arranged the fly so that it could also
pull on a small flexible fiber and we
calibrated that fiber to know how much
force was being created if it was
deflected a certain amount of a certain
distance at the same time we then also
put a recording pipette into the leg of
the fly so that we could measure the
spikes in the axons in the fly as well
there in the leg as well so let me show
you what this whole setup looks like
together so here on the top the top line
is the soma recording from this fast
motor neuron you can see the
depolarizations it's it's hyperpolarized
at first when the fly is not moving and
then depolarizes and fires some action
potentials and then the trace in the
middle is this what we call an electro
Maya gram this fiber in the leg is
detecting the axon spikes so you can see
that the spikes occur in time time
locked to the spikes in the soma and
then down the bottom is the distance
measurement of this of the flexible
force probe and positive direction is
flexion so you can see that when this
fast flexor motor neuron fire spikes
that there's big flexion events that
were detecting with force fiber okay and
so then what we can do with this is then
cause spikes in the mote in this motor
neuron that go those spikes travel out
to the axon and cause contraction of the
muscle fibers so here on the right the
either time-lock spikes arranged aligned
at this this vertical line you can see
that the spike in the cell body then
elicits a spike in the leg followed by a
twitch of the pro
and the probe goes about 50 microns
turns out that that's about the weight
of the fly the conversion is about 50
microns to about 10 micro Newtons and
the weight of the fly is about 10
micrometers and we can do this
repeatedly so here are multiple
deflections of the same in the same leg
and we can do this for all of the
different motor neurons that we found so
here is the intermediate round and these
twitches are about 10 times smaller than
we saw in the fast motor con so the vast
motor neuron is creating about 10 times
as much force as each spike in the
intermediate nerve so finally the slow
motor neurons were quite interesting
they were actually spiking at rest so
you can see here that in the absence of
current injection there is a spontaneous
spike rate of about 30 Hertz so at the
top here or individual traces with this
identify spikes up above you can see
both depolarizing and hyperpolarizing
events here are below that our spike
rasters for both depolarization and
hyperpolarization and you can see the
hyperpolarization removes the spikes and
the result of that of the cessation of
spiking is that the fly actually lets go
the probe a little bit so you can see
this negative going trace of the the
probe distance so that means that the
fly was initially placing force on the
probe and then it now let go okay and if
we plot the force per spike for these
three motor neurons you can see that
they cover a huge range of forces so
this is about three orders of magnitude
on the y-axis going from point one
micronewtons
for about ten extra spikes in the motor
in the slow mode or not those are the
green dots there it's a small end of the
range up to a single spike produces 10
microns again about the weight of fly
okay so this tells us something about
the organization of the motor neurons
controlling flexion in this one joint in
parallel with
those findings we find that each of
these motor neurons has a different lies
along a gradient of electrical
excitability we also find that during
spontaneous movements these motor
neurons are recruited from slow to fast
and a very quarterly recruitment
hierarchy we also find that when we
impose movements of the tibia that
there's sensory feedback to these motor
neurons that first recruit the slow
motor neurons and then the intermediate
neurons at higher at higher
perturbations stronger perturbations
okay so that's what we find in this in
our work so far and this we believe is
going to enable us to in the future map
the inputs to these different motor
neurons with iam circuit racing and
improvements in the genetic reagents
labeling either sensory circuits or the
pre motor circuits onto these motor
neurons we're also going to be able to
use these to study the coordinated
development of motor neuron electrical
properties the muscles and pre motor
circuits and we can do that with the man
lab who has been who has made a lot of
tools and made a lot of headway to that
into that research into that field and
then finally this ability to measure
sensory feedback to motor neurons allows
us to start to investigate how those
feedback circuits are modulated during
behavior including with neuromodulation
such as serotonergic activation and
other things like that which is
something that Claire Howard has been
investigating in the man lab so I'll
hand it off to her now and just want to
thank you for your time okay thank you
hi thanks so much for a great talk to my
colleague um my name is Claire Howard
and I recently graduated from my PhD in
Richard Mane's lab at Columbia
University and today I'm going to be
telling you about my work trying to
understand how locomotion is modulator
so we think of locomotion is a simple
behavior simply just putting one foot in
front of the other but for us and even
for simpler organisms like Drosophila
locomotion is actually a behavior that
needs to occur in a complicated and
complex environment
my favorite example of this is fast and
slow locomotion we use these two
different flavors of the same behavior
in order to engage with different
environmental circumstances fast we used
to run away from predators and slow we
use in order to engage with our
environment and even search for food
so my question fundamentally is kind of
how is locomotion modulated in order to
produce these different behavioral
outputs the circuitry in Drosophila are
responsible for locomotion is located in
the ventral nerve cord which is the
analog of the mammalian spinal cord and
this structure is composed of six Hemi
thoracic Nura mirrors each of which
contains the circuitry that innervates
one of the adult legs of the animal if
we zoom in on the circuitry a little bit
we can see that at its most fundamental
level it consists of motor neurons which
send signals to the periphery to induce
muscles to contract sensory neurons that
send information from the periphery back
to the system and a set of as-yet
uncharacterized inter neurons that
comprise the central pattern generator
or circuitry that produces oscillating
motor output so really our question is
how does a circuit like this that's
fundamentally static produce different
outputs to fit different contexts and
this is a question that has interested
scientists for a long time and I want to
highlight some work done in the
crustacean by Eve martyr and her group
at Brandeis University where they showed
that in an isolated central pattern
generating motor circuit application of
different substances with a term
neuromodulators can induce different
patterns of motor activity in this
circuit so really this is kind of the
foundation for our work trying to
understand if neuromodulatory substances
for us the neuromodulator serotonin are
responsible for helping a circuit like
the load emot-- locomotor circuit in
Drosophila adjust to different
behavioral environments but before I
tell you about some of the results we've
gotten in this area I want to take a
step back and think about why Drosophila
in particular and collaborations like
our unite team brain initiative grant
are so crucial for trying to under
stand there at modulation when it told
you so far is that a lot of groups have
looked at the effect of neuromodulators
on circuit dynamics and this is what
originally suggested to us that these
substances might be involved in
determining different motor outputs
however what we want to do is we want a
system where we can integrate this
understanding of circuit level analysis
in a behavioral context and even more
than that what we are interested in is
how that behavioral contest changes over
time in response to substrate
information under southla are really a
great model system in order to look at
some of these things because we have
great tools to access different circuits
but we also have a variety of behavioral
paradigms where we can look at different
sensory stimulation and in a
collaboration like this one when we're
working with people who work at the most
basic electro physiological level all
the way up to people who are interested
in questions of sensory integration it's
a really rich environment to start
asking these questions and integrating
data to give you a sense of how we look
at locomotor behavior I want to share
two different assays that we use in the
lab in order to understand how in this
or blocking one fly walker was developed
in our lab and won the arena
is something that we brought to the lab
in collaboration with Michael
Dickinson's lab at Caltech and this
brain initiative grant these two
different assays are complementary in
the types of approaches to locomotion
that we can use so where the arena is
low resolution and animals are simply
dots on the screen it provides a
wide-angle lens for high level readouts
like speed angular velocity interactions
between animals and position within the
arena that we can record over long
periods of time
in contrast the fly walker is much more
high-resolution as you can see here in
this image this allows us to look at
each footprint an individual takes but
it provides a much more narrow focus and
we can look at only short bouts of
locomotion as animals walk back and
forth across the screen from this system
we can get footprint by footprint
readouts which allow us to dissect how
long the steps are that animals are
taking how coordinated their gates are
and where their feet are placed as they
walk across
our veena and the combination of these
two approaches has been really useful in
dissecting the role of modulation for
example if we start with our arena
context we can generate a map for each
individual of their average locomotion
speed across a recording period and when
we activate certain urges neurons in the
ventral nerve cord we see that animals
slow down in response to this stimulus
but this actually doesn't give us an
understanding of why animals are slowing
down one hypothesis could be that
animals are just so disorganized by
activating the certain urging system
that they're not able to access faster
speeds because their legs are
uncoordinated this is where the fly
Walker comes in and in this system what
we're able to do is map for an
individual walking bout each foot
placement as the animal walks across the
screen you're shown an overlay as if the
animal was walking on a treadmill you
can see that every time the animal takes
a step it's very coordinated in where it
places its foot we can also look at
coordination by mapping the stance and
swing phases for each leg
here's stamps days when the animals leg
is on the ground is not going to bite
and swing phase when the animals leg is
swinging in the air is not in black we
can do this for all of the animals legs
and you can see that it forms this nice
checkerboard pattern suggesting that the
animals utilizing a highly coordinated
gait so what happens when we activate
certain nergic neurons well it turns out
these animals aren't uncoordinated at
all in fact they're highly coordinated
and you can see that their foot
placement remains intact so it's not
that activating certain urgent miron's
just totally disrupts these animals it
actually seems like we're putting them
in a coordinated state of slow
locomotion but I want to get back to the
question I posed at the beginning of the
talk how do these neuromodulatory
systems act to help animals adjust to
different behavioral contexts and in
order to do that we had to introduce
sensory stimulation to our assay and we
did that using a vibration paradigm
where we had animals walking in the rena
that would experience a sharp vibration
stimulus which is startling to these
animals control animals respond to this
particular set of behavioral adjustments
first they slow down then they have a
pause phase of their behavior and then
they rapidly accelerate and what we
think of as an escape phase however when
we prevents their emerging around from
being recruited into this system we see
that the patterning of this behavior is
dramatically different particularly the
pause phase while still present is
dramatically shorter at the moment we
don't really understand what these
different phases of behavior used for in
determining animal's responses to these
stimuli but one hypothesis that we have
is the pause phase is important for
animals to gather additional sensory
information before making behavioral
decisions so our next question is how is
there toning doing this at the level of
locomotor circuitry and the first
important thing to understand is that in
our modulator is like serotonin active
via a family of different receptors each
of which has distinct effects on the
downstream Sal in Drosophila in
serotonin these families are v HT 1 v 2
HT 7 and v HT 2 and what we find is that
consistent with the fact that these
receptors play different roles in
altering neuronal cell activity
different receptors play different roles
in modulating their energy dependent
behaviors like responses to vibrations
for example when we delete v HT 7 we see
a very similar phenotype - when we
delete the ability of the fly to secrete
serotonin however when we do a
difference to them and delete v HT 1a we
see a different phenotype entirely while
the pause phase here is maintained
animals reach a much slower ultimate
speed in their escape behavior and this
suggests that different receptors which
have different effects on downstream
cells are also mediating different
components of serotonins action on
locomotor circuitry to better understand
this we next ask the question where
these particular receptors expressed in
sensory motor circuits and not
surprisingly we found that different
receptor types are expressed in
different components of the locomotor
circuitry for example v HT 7 is extreme
primarily in distal mechana sensory
neurons proprioceptive neurons and motor
neurons this is particularly interesting
to us because work from our
collaborators particularly the Tuttle
lab has shown that proprioceptive organs
are important for conferring vibrations
sensation to the ventral nerve cord and
may therefore be particularly relevant
to the Haverhill analysis that we're
doing here conversely 5h t1a receptors
are expressed in a different population
altogether primarily more proximal
mccanna sensory neurons if we coordinate
this information with knowledge that
already exists in the literature about
what the role of these different
receptors are on downstream signaling
modalities we can start building a model
of how serotonin could be altering
sensory motor coupling in order to
change behavior for example 5ht 7
stimulates cyclic AMP II which
facilitates activity of downstream
neurons
whereas 5-ht 1a does the opposite so it
may be that activating these different
receptor types changes the weight of
sensory motor processing so missing it
more on distal and receptive organs so
getting back to the original goal of our
work to start building an integrated
model of modulation I've told you how
our work suggests that activation of
certain urges systems induces shifts in
sensory motor processing both sensory
and motor shifts and you think that this
is a really exciting area future work
when we can start testing these
hypotheses particularly with the
assistance of the Tuttle lab and their
electrophysiological models additionally
I've shown you that these systems impact
behavior including slowing animals down
and altering how they respond to sensory
stimuli I think the next step is to try
and link these two different systems and
understand how the effects of the
circuit level are ultimately being read
out as behavior and the way we'd like to
do that is by inactivating particular
receptor subtypes in different
subcomponents of locomotor circuitry and
seeing how this ultimately affects our
behavioral response with that I'd like
to thank all the people who are
instrumental in doing this work
including
my advisor Richard Mann collaborators
here at Columbia and elsewhere and also
highlighted in red other members of the
Uniting community who have been really
helpful as we've done this work and now
I want to hand it off to my colleagues
thank you so much for listening thank
you clear hello everyone my name is Luke
Resnick and I'm a PhD student in Tom
Clandon ins lab at Stanford University
and today I'm going to tell you about my
work on whole brain imaging of the
visual motor transformation animals use
visual information to guide their
behavior across a variety of contexts
one such example is goal-directed
navigation where an animal must use
visual and other sensory information to
navigate to some goal in all cases
visual information first enters the eye
and visual circuits extract behaviorally
relevant features these are features
such as the position of objects but also
things like optic flow which is the
coherent movement of the visual world as
the animal itself moves these features
then inform motor circuits that direct
behavior the degree to which these
visual circuits are directly coupled to
motor circuits is largely unknown what
examples exist both for very direct
connections as well as more indirect
connections through things like
navigation circuits and this
transformation is not simply
feed-forward but feedback loops exist at
every level for example motor signals
are related back to visual circuits in
the animals physical behavior itself
affects visual input as in the case of
optic flow overall these interactions
are a dynamic two-way street visual
information can guide behavior but the
behavior will in turn affect the visual
input upon the retina the picture that
emerges is complex with all circuits
interacting through nested loops across
multiple time scales and in a context or
behavioral state-dependent manner given
this interconnectivity and coordination
across multiple circuits I think it is
fair to say that we will never fully
understand these transformations if we
only look at each part in isolation and
that is the motivation that informs both
my project as well as the overarching
goals of our u19
to begin to understand these complex
networks I'm studying the fruit fly
Drosophila whose brain despite its
relative simplicity is still capable of
performing many of the same fundamental
computations as vertebrates in the case
of visually guided behaviors we know
that first visual circuits must extract
behaviorally relevant features in
vertebrates as well as in flies two
distinct visual features that are well
known to God locomotion our landmarks
and optic flow visual landmarks are
useful for correct estimation of heading
and spatial location while optic flow
helps the animal estimate its speed and
distance objects this is an image of a
Drosophila brain and on either side are
the optic lobes where early visual
processing takes place we have a
particularly detailed knowledge of these
early visual steps in processing these
early steps in visual processing and the
field is now continuing to get a better
sense of how these simple visual
features are related into the central
brain through these projection neurons
shown in various colors for my project
I'm using two photon imaging to record
neural activity throughout the entire
brain simultaneously when I started this
project Kevin Mann a postdoc in the lab
has just published the first work of
whole brain imaging and adult Ursula in
his paper he establishes the whole brain
imaging methodology in flies including
the technique for registering individual
fly brains to each other into a common
anatomical atlas this allows
quantitative comparisons between
individuals and between brain regions in
order to address the questions I'm
interested in the first thing I had to
do was implement several technical
modifications to this methodology namely
the fly must be able to walk during
imaging and we would like to show it
visual stimuli during this process in my
setup I'm imaging from the posterior
part of the head while maintaining full
optical access to the brain this is the
central brain and these are the two
optic lobes on either side
in this setup the flies walking on an
air suspended ball while visual stimuli
are presented on screens surrounding the
fly to measure neural activity I'm
expressing the calcium indicator gcamp
in all neurons in the brain in our
resident scanning microscope allows me
to image the entire brain volume twice a
second at cellular resolution and I'll
show you an overview of the experimental
pipeline I've developed gcamp neural
activity is measured simultaneously with
the TD tomato structural marker which is
used for motion correction and brain
registration between individuals visual
stimuli can be presented using software
developed in-house with the help of an
electrical engineering PhD student
Stephen Hirst
the Flies walking trajectory is measured
using thick track software which tracks
the movement of the wall at the end of
each experiment a high-resolution scan
is taken and later used to align
individual brains to each other I've
been working on developing new models to
extract the brain signals and interpret
them as they relate to visual stimuli
and behavior next I will show you the
results of one of those models let's
focus on the question what regions of
the Drosophila brain contain information
that can be used to predict the forward
and rotational velocity of the fly these
two behaviors moving forward and turning
can potentially be thought of as the two
core knobs the animal has access to for
directing its navigation without getting
too into the details of the analysis let
me just say for those interested that I
used principal components analysis
followed by a regularized and cross
validated linear model using the
principle the principal components as
input features and the Flies walking
velocity as the output prediction so
here I'm showing you a single slice of
the fly brain with each voxel colored
based on how well it can predict the
Flies forward and rotational velocity
using this method we identify many
regions are
to have some role in motor control such
as the protis ebrill bridge layers of
the fan-shaped body and regions
containing high densities of descending
motor neurons well we also identify many
new regions that we are excited to
explore using this model we can
accurately predict the velocity of the
fly given the neural data here in black
I'm plotting the true velocity of the
fly in the red is the models prediction
the top graph is the floor velocity and
the bottom is rotational velocity this
is over a period of four minutes as you
can see the model matches the true days
data reasonably well lending to lending
support to the validity of the model the
final bit of data I'd like to show you
is the same analysis except now I'm
showing you one of the optic lobes of
the fly and despite this particular fly
walking in complete darkness there's
clearly an abundance of motor related
signals present the spatial extent of
these signals is much more dramatic than
was previously expected in particular
there are signals present in layers of
the medulla which would constitute the
earliest visual circuit neuro pill
containing stop-motion signals now why
would there be extensive motor signals
in the earliest sensory circuits whose
job it is to process visual information
as I mentioned in the introduction self
motion of an animal will change the
visual input that animal experiences so
it could certainly benefit these early
circuits to know what visual experiences
they might expect and adjust their
computations appropriately for example
if the animal is moving quickly these
circuits may want to be in a mode
optimized to efficiently extract
information through quickly changing
visual scenes so what I've shown you is
I can image the whole brain of a fly
during walking and visual stimulation
and the behavioral signals can be
extracted using PCA and linear models my
next steps will be to present a suite of
visual stimuli while recording walking
behavior continue to map the visual
motor transformation across the entire
brain and ultimately identified the
neurons underlying step
in the transformation finally I would
like to thank my mentor Tom Clendenen
and the Clendenin lab as well as the
u-19 project group whose
interdisciplinary collaboration has made
this complex project possible in
particular insights on the central
complex from the Dickinson and Wilson
lab has helped me conceptualize and
design my project the Dickinson lab has
led the design and manufacture of the
foam balls and ball holder we used to
track the Flies locomotion and the
Wilson lab has helped us get the Fick
track software for tracking fly
locomotion up and running the druckmann
lab has helped us develop and explore
various flavors of models to relate
interactivity to the visual and motor
signals I look forward to our continued
collaboration especially the insights
coming from the Wilson title and man
labs about the logic of the distending
motor neurons which contains many
implications to my work I also look
forward to the technological development
in the Wilson lab for tracking
individual legs of the fly as it walks
on the ball which could give us a more
accurate understanding of the Flies
locomotion in collaboration with the
druckmann lab promises teals many more
interesting and informative models and I
thank you for your attention
and now I'd like to hand it off to my
colleague Sasha thank you for that
introduction
imagine I need to get to the Washington
Monument from from Chinatown in
Washington DC but first you'll you'll
never get out with your gold is the map
stored in my memory either in your head
or on your phone but once you see that
the Washington Monument you no longer
need this map and you can simply head
towards the slalom mark by using
division student behavior is an integral
part of navigation and it's a window
into the into the the the other rhythms
that the brain uses to guide the animal
towards different goals this example
shows that some sometimes navigation is
driven by goals in working out the
memory when goals are obscure or out of
sight and sometimes it's driven by
sensory cues immediately perceptible in
the environment how the brain integrates
these inputs to competitor alsa tearing
remains a major open question but first
we need to answer where do these
securing us signals converge we are the
rest this question by studying cells at
an information bottleneck precisely
cells in the neck of the fly there are
100,000 neurons in the fly's brain and
roughly 10,000 in the spinal cord and
only 350 these descending neurons that
carry information from the brain to the
spinal cord and in this talk I'll show
you data from from from one of these
cells we focus on a cell called e 2
because it's a Anatomy suggests a role
in the constitutive walking behavior and
this cell gets its my inputs from a
promoter region called the lateral
access it's very low that is thought to
be about the end of the informing motor
come commands for this spinal cord in
other insects and also in flies we're
performing whole cell recordings from
flights walking on a floating ball and
we use the rotary rotational velocity of
this ball as the measure of ice turning
the behavior this data shows the fly
turning the zero is now turning and
changes above zero is returning and
below left turning I'm making a
simultaneous recording of the same a two
cell from the left and the right side
and here's an example the trace the
middle trace shows activity in the right
cell and the bottom trees in the left
and you'll notice that these cells are
generally anti coral reticulated just
before right turns there is a burst of
activity in the right cell and just
before left turns there's a burst of
activity in the left so if we plot the
activity of the left versus the right a
to sell
the function of searing red is right
turning blue is left turning when the
left cell is more active than the right
the fly is more likely to be turning
left and and and vice versa and in fact
we can read off the direction and the
magnitude of Teheran by looking at the
difference of activity between both of
these cells we can also derive returns
by asymmetrically activating these these
neurons I've shown you that spontaneous
turning converges on to a two neurons
and now I shall show you the external
sensory drives also converge one to
these same cells we discovered that
these neurons integrate multiple sensory
drives and the integrate both are
attractive and aversive cues but first I
have to tell you that $0.05
odors with with vir and he T by using
their antennae if we present lab
sterilized
odor to the fly the fly turns towards
that that odor and if we represent lat
typical iced heat the fly will turn away
from that heat but in both of these
cases activity of a two predicts the the
directions direction of the Flies turn
this tells us two important things first
e 2 is downstream from both both of
these sensory drives and second it's
involved in both approach and avoidance
behavior I've shown you spontaneous and
sensory evolved returning and now I'll
show you turning based on an internal
spatial call there's a region called the
central complex in the fly that contains
maps of space it also encodes spatial
goals and maps of subsidies are useless
if you can't use them to guide turning
and we want relief circuits in the
central car complex are used to guide
materials by the sea to this descending
Europe having a compass is fundamental
to navigation it turns out that the fire
has a built-in compass there is located
in the circular structure
in the flies central central complex
strangely it physically looks like an
actual compass adjacent cells in this
structure and coat adjacent angle so for
my two heading and these arrows in grey
represent where the fly thinks it's
going and there's a bump of activity
that moves around in a circle as the fly
turns essentially working as a as a
compass needle to examine a to role in
central complex evoked returning we
first had to inject the turning signal
into the central complex and let me just
give you some intuition for these
experts experiments so your goal is to
walk north and your compass reads north
but someone to trip your compass to
point East and for a moment you will
feel lost and I want to correct your
course by it by by turning towards to
the north we can do something like that
with flies we can monitor the position
of the bump by using calcium imaging and
when we artificially set it to a
different direction flights will the
encounter turn to bring the bump
activates in a initial position and as
these turns that we call central complex
Evoque turns and we'd like to monitor
the activity of a to my during these
turns here's an example trial the
circulars the tractor that I just showed
you it's unfolded on the y-axis and the
red line is the purple position of the
pump over time the pump is initially in
this local location
and we cause a punk jog around this time
and the bumps today's at this new
location until this time but it returns
back to its initial position we
typically see a large turn that precedes
this bump return of this turn is
particularly by a burst of a flow of
activity in the a two cell and this
effect has been consistent across the
rails and and flies in the future to
understand how competing steering
signals I resolved at the level of a two
neurons we will need to identify your
inputs onto these cells and Ivan
able to make progress in this direction
with the help of the full fly brain
electron microscopy data and using this
data we found this defending neurons and
we identified hundreds of their inputs
in the in the brain for example we've
identified neurons that directly connect
the compasses of the system with a two
satiric descending yarns to summarize
how sensory cues and internal cognitive
drives are integrated to guide motor
commands is a major open question and we
made progress towards this question by
discovering neurons that influence
occurring during walking aversive and a
relative sensitivity drives converge
onto these same cells and see tearing
drives based on an internal goal also
converges onto the same neurons
so these satiric neurons are an
important starting point for future
studies that will examine how conflicts
between external and and and internal
drives are are resolved this project has
a number of connections to other members
of the brain initiative team the the
Tuthill and the man Labs are
investigating the targets of steering
the sending neurons in the ventral nerve
cord the Clendenen lab is investigating
the representation of steering signals
in the visual system the dickinson lab
is investigating the compass system in
the central complex and it's can
connection to see tearing behavior and
the de Rahman lab is using computational
model modeling to explore the potential
network dynamics of composites appearing
in the interactions and our next speaker
emily Parker will tell you about a
behavior called path the integration we
think this behavior is driven by the
central complex which connects
the securing dissenting neurons I have
just talked about and thereby engages
the motor circuits in the DNC thanks
Sasha my name is Emily Palmer and I'm a
second year grad student in the
Dickinson lab and I'll be talking today
about a model of IDEO thetic past
integration in the 1970s and 80s a
series of experiments were done with the
desert ant cat a glyphis that studied
their long foraging excursions away from
their nest so on these outbound
excursions the ants would walk tens of
meters or even hundreds of meters away
from their nest
until they encountered a food sight in
nature and at that point they would
enter the second phase of their search
when they would turn and moth directly
back to their nest from that food sight
and so this told researchers that the
ants were performing a behavior called
path integration or dead reckoning where
they had an internal internal map stored
of their position relative to their nest
or their home site and this behavior is
really interesting because it allows
them to walk directly back to the nest
rather than retracing their steps on
their outbound trajectory once the ants
got back to where they believed in the
nest should be they entered the third
phase of their search called local
search and in this stage they would
search in the area around where they
believe the nest should be spending the
most time immediately around their nest
opening and less time further away and
it turns out that not only do these
virtuosic desert ants perform local
search but we also see it in flies
Vincent adhere in particular found that
flies will perform local search around a
food site in nature trying to capitalize
on the patchiness of food where they'll
loop out from assumes that food sight
looking for other food sights before
looping back to it
more recently Ramon Corps Foss a postdoc
in the Dickinson lab found that he could
elicit local search with epigenetic
activation of sugar receptors in the
fly's brain in Vermont experiments he
had them walk around in a circular arena
and when they entered that little gray
dot in the sound
the arena a red light would come on and
give them that sugar reward and from
here on out I'll refer to that so and
ask the activation zone or the food site
for convenience now before the
activation was turned on before they
entered that great dot the Flies
wouldn't exhibit any preference for any
real for any area in the arena they
would kind of walk around the walls
sometimes crossed the center of the
arena but after the activation turn on
we saw a very different behavior where
now the Flies have stayed very close to
that effective food sight going on local
searches where they loop away from the
food and then come back to it the
problem with these dances or local
searches is that they're so tortuous
that they're very hard to to analyze to
start to unravel these behaviors Ameer
Baba honey
another postdoc in the lab constrained
the Flies to circular channels rather
than these open circular arenas now the
Flies are allowed to walk in the circle
for a few minutes before the activation
is enabled and once the activation is
enabled when they enter the activation
site at the south end of the channel the
red light is again turned on and they
get the sugar reward now before that is
turned on as in the open arena case we
see no preference for any region of the
arena and they just walk around in
circles sometimes reversing but tending
to just walk in one direction
indefinitely once the activation is
enabled however we see the same behavior
that we saw in 2d but now in a 1d case
where they'll stay very close to the
activation site and then occasionally
make excursions away from it looking for
other activation sites we became really
interested however in the behavior after
the activation is disabled which spoke
to us about what happened when the fly
walks away from the food site and comes
back and the food is no longer there to
analyze these cases we term the distance
between the food and the first turn are
zero and the distance between those two
consecutive turns are one where there's
no food stimulus between those two turns
when we plot r0 and r1 against each
other where each dot on this plot is a
different slide we find a very
your relationship here and this
confirmed to us that the flies were
performing path integration because it
meant that the flies were keeping track
of how far away from the food they
walked before coming back in the other
direction we said a relationship to this
data and found what we expected which
was this linear relationship and now
this became a path integration problem
where the r-1 distance that second run
is equal to the integrated distance from
the food to the first turn plus some
constant C so we decompose that second
run length into these two components now
if we assume that local search aims to
take advantage of the patchiness of food
in nature it follows that the algorithms
they're using should be able to handle
finding two food sites in their
environment and so that's what we look
to investigate next in these cases when
there are two activation sites the fly
first will search around that first
activation site and then at some point
because of the variability in the first
excursion distance it comes across the
second and once it finds a second rather
than just switching to dancing over that
new food site the fly searches between
the two and what was really interesting
to us here was that the outbound
distance away from the food is shorter
on average than the distance between the
foods which means that their algorithm
somehow is able to keep track of what
direction they're walking in and sure
that they cover both of the food sites
so in this one food case again we termed
the r0 the distance between the food in
the first turn now we turn term r0 the
distance between the first food that
they encounter in that first turn so
this is effectively saying that this is
still a path integration problem but now
we're going to be integrating from the
first food that we found so that's when
our step counter is enabled and when we
plot this data we not only find the same
linear relationship but we find the same
C value as well which told us that even
though there was a second food found the
Flies for an undergoing any sort of
state change they were using the same
algorithm to handle both the search in
the month
case in the tooth loop case using our
integrated relationship we now have this
parsimonious model of how lies our path
integrating to perform localization so
they go outbound from their first food
at some point they execute a turn and
ask this reversal they choose their next
run length based on the integrated
distance from the food to that turn plus
some constant C on that way on that
trajectory they come across another food
and that resets their counter at the
reversal they choose their next run
length and so on but at some point
because of the variability in their
initial run length they can find the
second food and when this happens at
that next reversal because their
integrator started at that first good
site they're ensured that their next run
will pass both of those foods this
happens in both directions and proceeds
indefinitely for the rest of the search
we implemented this model using a state
transition diagram which is a tool
commonly used in computer science for
things like autonomous driving where we
have discrete states that the actor can
take on like stopped or walking
connected by probabilistic or
deterministic transitions and this model
gives us gives us very realistic traces
it's very similar to the data that we
collected so you see that it not only
works in the one suitcase before the
simulated slide times the second food
but it also it can handle when the
applied or the fictive slide has
knowledge of both of the food sights we
can also tell the model that there are
more foods than this in different
geometries and each of these makes a
prediction about how fly will behave in
a new job or untested geometry so for
example the top trace has three evenly
spaced foods we can test a real fly in
that same configuration and both the
model and the real slide should create
should perform identically moving
forward we're really interested in
finding out how flies execute this on a
neural basis so what is the underlying
neural circuitry governing path
integration and luckily because we're
part of this consortium
we can look to the other labs who are
also involved in this project so for
example the Clinton and lab is looking
at whole brain imaging so we can have a
tethered slide route where a fly's
walking on a ball in the head fixed
tether and if we image the whole brain
that could tell us information about
which regions of the brain are involved
in the path integration process the
title lab and the man Labs are working
on proprioception Meccano reception and
since path integration requires that the
Flies are able to integrate they must be
counting their steps away from the food
and so if we inhibit or silenced
proprioceptive or mechanoreceptors in
the Flies they should no longer be able
to count how far they're walking the
Wilson lab is working on steering and
compass systems in the fly's brain if we
inhibit the or to silence the Flies
ability to steer they should no longer
be able to navigate back to the food
side so we might see a reduced ability
for them to reverse and walk back
towards the food and all of these
changes are also implementable in our
model so again with that example of
silencing the ability to steer if we
turned off the ability of the model to
reverse we should see the model and the
Flies perform identically thanks thank
you for that outstanding presentation
for additional panels on the NIH brain
initiative you our agenda on our events
page as a final reminder the panelists
will follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email thank you again for
your participation